[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
hey my girl and i started that show oh
double sturby couples therapy
isn't it great when your friends put you
on good shows yes this is good
yeah it's good it's it's not a reality
show it's like a it's like a documentary
series series 10-part series sim part
series follows several couples
through their like therapy some of them
off the bound like just
just separate yeah some walls but you're
like yo
okay if they don't have kids it's like
what are you doing yeah what are you
doing
bro that one dude is so the the black
couple
oh the that guy insurance yeah he's
great he's great he's great he starts
laughing
yeah he's off because they laughing and
crying
well no he's not crying because they go
well because she's real mean all the
time i guess
me and he's like like i'll be good he's
like like i help everything out for like
six days and sunday comes i do one thing
i'll take out the trash
he's like she's just mean to me yeah and
then the therapist is like well what if
on that
that seventh day you tried and didn't
mess up and he goes
dude laughs like belly laugh and he goes
oh that's a good one he goes nah man she
liked this no matter what
but she is cause like he goes he's the
puerto rican girl right uh i don't know
if she's puerto rican but
yeah i think so yeah she's the one that
got punched in the face yeah yeah
he was like she'll [ __ ] he goes i'm at
work
she'll call i don't answer she'll call
again just call again and then next
thing you know i get a text message
and then she goes you know all these
ceos you know they'll answer their
wife's calls he goes i'm not a ceo
yeah because i want to be i want to
people yeah
because i'm just [ __ ] regular dude
lesbian couple with the transgender yeah
super interesting bro they are pretty
interesting because i don't know
anything about their world so when like
they fight
you know just like any other couple and
the one had
bottom surgery and she was a a man was a
full-blown woman yeah but she's the
guy the earner she makes all the money
okay yeah and so she
that girl on the left think she holds it
over her head yes it's so interesting
and the girl on the left wants to have a
baby yeah yeah but homegirl
uh the girl on the left want to have a
baby yeah yellow transgender
is saying let's you know like she just
transitioned
she's transitioning and she goes i don't
know if i'm ready to be a mom yet she's
like
just like yeah just figuring it out and
so she's she thinks she's being selfish
yeah which i'm like all right hey ease
the [ __ ] up yeah you know what i'm going
home girl on the right
yeah yeah the the trans yeah cause she's
a new mom
yeah i get that that's i mean that's
pretty logical it's like hey
you know i just transitioned and she's
like chill yeah it's like chill how good
is that there you go
the therapist is dope here's what don't
think about the therapist
she goes to a therapist and they show
her talking to her yes
what yeah she goes to like the head but
it makes so much sense because to be
able to deal
with the [ __ ] that she has you need to
release your problems she's got a
relationship she has to talk to somebody
this lady's been doing it longer than
her
and so that later i just feel like i
have so much power over these people and
it's draining
yes oh man there's this one couple uh
the guy the guy the guy that uh
he just he wants to have sex every day
he has a problem yeah
he's like i need it he goes i don't see
a problem with he goes i don't have sex
every day
i mean we eat we drink we sleep and i
want sex every day that's just normal to
do that you're the same girl
oh yeah bruh she tried to she tried to
surprise him with some dope sex
like fun set ordinary for his birthday
and he was mad about it
why because he was like well it's only
for my birthday why can't this be all
the time
yeah and it's like this [ __ ] you know
he's difficult dude he's kind of
smart he's so smart yeah that's the
thing about him and the therapist will
go back and forth and he yeah
kind of sticks it to her uh-huh and then
before they go and she's like will you
please be nice he's a cupcake yeah yeah
i love him that's me my girl
before we go anywhere my girl's like
will you please be cool
oh yeah [ __ ] drama man someone said
something stupid i can't help
you think i'm gonna do it i can't hold
my tongue now she's like right my
family's dead yeah
no roasting oh dude what about the uh
other couple
there's like a third couple i think uh
oh there's a mexican couple
yeah we're trying to make it a puerto
rican out there in new york oh they're
not mexican oh okay but yeah i feel yeah
you feel me
you feel me with them because i was
complete he's completely yeah he's going
to the bottom left but uh
that couple yeah the one with the the
guy the one you're the eyes closed the
new york hat
with the girl in the yellow shirt right
no yeah yeah right there yeah
them they break it up spoil it but they
spoiler
it's not spoiler because they announced
in the first episode the first episode
they broke up so it shows their last day
therapy and that backtracks
but um one of her things was
because he has so he's he works he works
in fashion
right okay here's this thing here's a
boom i don't like it but he does yeah
i guess he works he works in fashion
okay and
i know what the [ __ ] blue venus yeah
well that's that's big in new york
though
okay but uh he he works in fashion he
works around a lot of women yeah right
and so sometimes like you know after
work they'll go have
an outing so like dapper dan yeah and
she
don't [ __ ] with that you know because
you don't want to go anywhere she don't
want to go anywhere does he invite her
no it's just like he's just with his
co-workers it's like yeah like
we yeah if we go ahead and got food
after this yeah
that's that's what he's doing you know
and she and she doesn't uh
predominately women around her yeah
cause he's in fashion and she doesn't
uh uh trust him or whatever
so do you and your girl watch it and
like you can pick up tips like
oh yeah
the thing about me is like yeah i was in
cheerleading i got you i have
so many friends that are women yeah like
literally there was times i was the only
dude
on the [ __ ] team though yeah yeah i
got a football team i have a lot of
male friends exactly so that's just my
world so i talked to so many of them
because all of my friends they're all
baddies to be
[Music]
so it's like tough so i have to explain
every
girl dude and i don't mind doing it you
know it's like i just
trust you though yeah she trusts me
though but you know like like if she was
to act like
uh the whole girl right you guys
wouldn't make it i wouldn't we wouldn't
make it i'd go [ __ ] crazy
but i don't like that that's where i
find the compromise of just explaining
like
oh this is such a such i know here's the
history of this because i'm always like
it would have [ __ ] happened already
yeah yeah knowing you
right now hell yeah yeah it would have
[ __ ] happened yeah it would have
happened you know what i mean but it but
it didn't but like
i don't know it's just you know and i
get it like most straight dudes aren't
just like strictly friends with like a
bunch
of women it'd be tough it'd be tough
it'd be tough especially
yeah especially the limit should be
three
man i got like he has like 50 50 yeah
chapel's a unicorn yeah like a straight
guy because using cheerleading
that's just that's just what my world
was for [ __ ] 12 years and now he's
getting in shape
we worked out two days in a row two days
in a row mark uh hella mark harley with
us yeah
he's basically our trainer i know right
yeah he just formed in our trainer
yeah it's weird because we get to early
in the morning like what do you what do
you guys think about doing like i don't
know what do you want to do
i think yeah
and by the way 190. 190 yeah 190.
you sure jay doesn't believe it jay
didn't believe i can't wait because what
you were 185. i was 185 was the scale
yep oh yeah five pounds yeah yeah five
pounds i believe that but why would you
saying 20
on the in the group chat jay's like i
find it hard to believe you gained 20
pounds in
a month well because uh january january
i want to start this
fitness journey i was 153. oh yeah i
think you're like two now
what you're welcome you're 190 now yeah
in january no no
no in january put on 40 pounds in two
months
well listen i gained oh i can't i can't
wait i can't wait until i guess get here
no yeah because he's gonna be like what
okay
bradley's even like no bro
even if you're on gear running like
heavy amounts of gear it'd be down there
and pop
literally i don't think you start off at
153
yeah you could you see i was all skinny
yeah yeah yeah you're 180 malachite
that's fine i wasn't one on ten you was
170. i would get one i would give
i'm trying to tell you hold on let me
see because i got back 53 minutes 153
bro i get i'm an ectomorph you all like
teasing and stuff like that you're not
170 ectomorph i was 153 you saw me i
can't wait for bradley sit down there
and you guys are gonna look like
the number [ __ ] zero one no no no it'd
be ten if you're sitting here you look
like zero one like a race car
are you zero one he's jack uh he told me
the story how y'all was lifting oh we'll
talk about when he goes
on 600 pounds lives don't gain 40 pounds
the big fat one put on 30 in like six
months
she was all sad
[Laughter]
she had the scale she got a scale
talking to the doctor
he was like how's the diving she's like
really good you know i haven't seen you
know he's like this kitchen
scale she put on 30 he's all
that poor doctor's off and i laugh in
his throat
just [ __ ] oh you know what else i'm
on the episode two to the of the takashi
doc it's so much better than that hulu
one that's showtime takashi
the best thing about the hulu one is
when they he made the music video of him
they showed everything and they also
show him getting head too
in the showtime one oh they showed it
yeah they show that in a music video
yeah because he was doing wild [ __ ] just
to gain traction so
he was doing that posted posted [ __ ]
all the stuff
but then what the funniest part about on
uh episode two it shows how he's getting
involved in treyway and then uh the real
treyway gangster i forget his name
launch the record company right and then
he
like uh assigned other gang members like
his or stuff like that
well that man just started feeling
himself because he was like in all the
videos
yeah he was like on the videos and took
control yeah then he stopped
like he'd got takashi away from the
original trayway
shoddy right yeah yeah that was in jail
right
yeah it was a joke yeah so he got him
out of the contract with the original
trade way
start his own trayway uh productions and
it's funny to watch these
hardcore game like hardcore trayway
gangsters like yeah man it's just not
cool man
like like he's like you know it's just
like what he did they're hurt yeah
they're like
yeah they're like like it's just not the
way we operate so takashi wasn't
in in the gang at first it wasn't he was
co-signed
no when he was in the game at first and
then
got out of prison was like i'm gonna
launch a record company
and then met takashi and then when he
met takashi
they kind of like they brought him in as
their own like he was
basically trayway because he was [ __ ]
with us and i brought him to like to my
mom's house
yeah but it's funny to watch like you
always think like gangsters don't
like like mess around like real people
but they do man
he's like yeah i brought in my mom's
house man yeah
you're like oh this you feel bad for
these dancers yeah like because they've
spent time in that yeah they're having
that they're like
he he shared bread with my mom man yeah
they're like sad about it
sham said you remember they also showed
the actual video remember when he gets
kidnapped in the car
yeah yeah yeah they have video from the
limo the actual car you get kidnapped in
i remember because they showed that in
the uh in
a hulu did they really yeah yeah the
video the guy it wasn't but it wasn't it
wasn't just the actual video them
driving
it just got a lot more meteor in here
oh you can put it anywhere yeah you can
set it outside
uh double x top xl bottom
oh but they're big they're made for
stickies yeah james harden jersey came
in are you still double x
yeah okay cool yeah i gotta get that to
you no problem
oh yeah black one holy [ __ ] that took
forever yeah it took forever but [ __ ]
oh no didn't it originally say it was
gonna come in mark yeah nice
i totally forgot about it you forgot
about that yeah i forgot about it
i forgot about it i got a good memory
yeah i forgot i was like oh [ __ ] this is
brendan's yeah
yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] do i get a
double double x
[ __ ] it reminded me of that dumb ass
[ __ ] what was the bet
you can't even remember the best the
super bowl right on the same
sinks yeah that one oh yeah well because
the original the irving old school one
was for the bet
on uh the uh
ryan garcia garcia yeah and then this
this was for
the saints didn't go to superman you
know and i hated this thing i don't know
why you feel bad for me yeah
it's all good yeah but yeah bro i'm
happy about this
that's good mm-hmm so you feel like
you're doing good you get to 190
190 bro yeah 10 pounds away and when
bradley says i want you to tell me
you've put on 40 pounds
right now come on in dog what up you're
rallying me oh yeah
yeah you're right here man
yeah come on man yeah what's up big dog
how you doing to your brother as always
we missed you at the gym this morning
yeah we were there bright and early is
this my mic
yeah yeah that's right this place is
crazy
today's episode with bradley martin is
brought to you by the kratom experts at
super speciosa that's right
you know your boy here has always create
them up and you might want to try kratom
but it's the wild west out there you
gotta trust your source
you need proper pure kratom that's why
i only take superspeciosa because unlike
other guys superspeciosa keeps their
kratom the way
nature intended and it is pure man and
you can trust it all right
i take it for every podcast stand up
working out i love this stuff i swear by
it uh and now's the time for you to try
it because you can trust
super speech yoshi alright also you can
save 20 off so go to
leaf dot com slash fighter that's get
super l e
a f dot com slash fighter promo code
fighter for 20
off that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
fighter
this place is crazy this is the wow
i'm really impressed thank you so much
you guys are doing it for real yeah man
yeah but you guys have a little podcast
area too right yeah
in the gym um but i stopped doing the
podcast i do them at my house now i just
and i haven't done them consistently for
some time so i'm a little bit ashamed of
myself yeah you got to be consistent
well you're putting out youtube videos
though yeah like you kind of dominate
that youtube world yeah i've been doing
youtube stuff for
for years now but this honestly is one
of my favorite my favorite mediums for
you i love it yeah i think it's the best
man
yeah i don't mean to interrupt you go
ahead no you just you you learn the most
about people like because
everyone like we all like for example i
do things you know like i work out
everyone does a thing
yeah but this is the kind of like spot
where you really get to know someone
correct
you really develop a real connection
with people yeah i think uh
so for the listeners i think to just to
kick it off i think what
i'm so grateful for you because you know
you know i grew up in football and
finding stuff like that and i've been in
gyms all my life
and then you know my uncle was mr
universe i grew up in venice
in the summers as kids so golds was like
mecca yeah man so
my aunt was mrs universe so like i love
that bodybuilding world and like working
out and that was my thing since i was
six man six to my mid-20s and then
you know i retired and i was just like
i've been doing that all my life like i
gotta find something else so then i got
into biking
so i've been biking a ton and then i'd
know i
hit up my trainer at boxing in santa
monica would hit mitts and do like a
circuit workout yeah and even that i was
god i'm so [ __ ] over this man i'm
just gonna keep riding my bike
but i wasn't getting that great of shape
like i like to be you know kind of fit
and then chappelle was like hey man
people keep hitting me up
saying there's this gym in woodland
hills which is you know my
stomping grounds yeah and i'm like no i
would know about it he's like no i'm
telling you dude someone said
you need to go up there and i go well
send me the name of it you know it's
zoo jim and i'm like uh zoo culture and
i'm like okay and then uh
you know i don't i don't see stuff on
social media so i go hey look up the
the profile chappelle sent to me since
we're like that's in woodland hills
he's like yeah and they're open during
the pandemic where the [ __ ]
so then so then i see you as the owner i
go on youtube
and then originally i'm like is he like
one of those you know what you meet some
guys you're like you see one of those
guys who
seems like cool has [ __ ] together and
you meet him like a total tool
you know what i'm saying like it's so
heartbreaking like when you see
people on camera they meet them and you
like you know you oh i don't know you
could just be a dick
and so i get it it's not conversation
so i i get to the gym and like bro take
your mask out what are you doing i was
like
really now you do the [ __ ] you know so
then uh
the guy at the front and then you come
around and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's the
owner then you and i start talking
i'm like he's a down ass dude yeah i
feel like i was talking to myself yeah
you and i
we vibe right away and i was like oh
this is my home
i came home man it was crazy too man
we're working on like i'm working on
buying a warehouse right around the
corner
like a crazy big warehouse like 30 000
square feet i'm going to make the gym
crazy you make it even bigger yeah so
the gym that i'm in now
is 30 is 7 500 square feet the the
warehouse that we're looking at is 30
000.
[ __ ] and but here's what's crazy is you
could definitely use the space
because like on certain days you go in
there and it's packed yeah
pop it yeah it's definitely everybody we
joke about it
everybody and [ __ ] like me and him are
the ugliest people in the gym oh yeah
and that's for sure
and i've accepted that and you know what
it motivates me
it really does real talk like being in
that gym in the difference of like
other gyms that i've been to yeah
there's just something about the
energy in zoo culture where i'm like man
i [ __ ] i feel it you know i want to
like
do it it makes me want to do it because
i don't come from weight lifting i was a
competitive cheerleader like that's what
i did
yeah and uh but you know can't cheer
forever so once i quit you know i needed
to find something
and i would just go to these gyms but it
wasn't like it just didn't
hit hit right but i don't know like this
is the first time i've ever
felt where i've gone to gym and like hit
right like somebody had a shirt after
like two guys had their shirt off
today and i'm like [ __ ] y'all work out
with your shirts
who no i looked at chapelle
dude whatever you don't want to take
your shirt off you don't want to take
like is is this make-a-wish is does he
have cancer
dude he sent me some milk yeah
is he malnourished someone get repaired
man
no i'm telling you i looked at you i'm
like can you imagine taking your shirt
off
and they're just like that game well
yesterday we were working out
and i've been mentioning years ago flat
bench invention years
okay so his boy mark shot the handsome
ass mark
he's distractingly handsome we're
benching i'm like i guess i've been i
was nervous because mark's strong as
[ __ ]
you hadn't been a long time huh years
dude a flat bench i can't
i can't i can't tell you last time i did
a flat bench i'm not around flat benches
and uh mark's like yeah mark's like you
wanna do 225 i'm like yeah he's like
what did you do in college i'm like like
26.
so we get on there we knock out you know
15. and then he goes you want to do 315
i was like i guess dude
you guys before the omen i was like i
guess man
he puts 315 on i do it i think four or
five times so you got six
six yeah yeah i did six strong though
yeah not bad yeah
solid but then you're like oh oh cool
you guys
no but not not like mean you're just
like oh you guys are left in three votes
yeah i don't know you trying to get on
your chest to be fair i was like hidden
chests and arms and i was like oh that's
already loaded i was warmed up i was
like let me jump in there yeah and i was
like i'll probably get like
eight or nine how many do you do
fourteen well like he could have did
like 20
you could have done so i was like he
could have been waiting but it was it
was but he's really he was like god you
guys doing good
man
i'm like let's get the [ __ ] up
it was so positive now today listen it's
that's 345's on each side
yeah okay okay 315. and you maxed that
but yeah man you six yeah
yeah you you created a solid environment
though no it's it's crazy like because
that'd always been the goal and it's
it's a place definitely where people
are whether they're like super like
minded on like their
exact goal like because there's people
who want to be bodybuilders or like
fitness influencers or
you know work on crossfit or be
powerlifters right but
whether whether or not they're like on
the same path people seem to really like
help each other and like help like for
for example like they'll be bodybuilders
who like
maybe need a better bench press and
there's powerless who like why don't you
try this why don't you try that instead
of like
dividing and conquering it's more like
there's none of that and the other thing
too is like if you go to other gyms i
won't mention it's like
you know it's it's tough to say but you
know
i'll get harassed a little bit like
that's fighting questions like
i'm basically doing a podcast every time
i work out yeah they're nobody [ __ ] me
like they're
again they're talking about their
[ __ ] workouts everyone's there to
work out
or they have their own [ __ ] popping yeah
like you always see some
soul dude and the other dudes film it
like everyone's in their own world doing
their own [ __ ]
they have a goal to achieve they don't
give a [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah everyone is on everyone's for
sure on their own path and it's a cool
environment because like when you're
around then you see other people
striving to like be better yeah it makes
you be like i want to work a little bit
harder
and then at the same time when you have
people who like you know like if you're
there long enough you'll see kind of the
same people
and it's it's not like a weird like oh
i'm stronger i'm bigger and whatever
than you like it's a
they seem more approachable and you can
ask them questions and like they're more
than likely oh they give me tips all the
time
yeah yeah so it's it's i'm glad you guys
see that man you guys i know you guys
haven't been there for that long but the
longer you're there the better and
and i i really hope like i really hope i
can finish this deal with that that new
building because it's going to be
crazy man i can't wait we might be
neighbors because i'm looking at
studio space over the two oh [ __ ]
come on now we're gonna fly we expand
these wings this spot's crazy though
yeah this is like a whole compound
obviously we're just in this room and
that's what they see
but we should like you know i shoot my
showtime shows in the front there and
then we have the whole
bay here where they edit stuff then we
shoot shows back there
how do my food truck diaries how long
have you been doing podcast stuff uh
like podcasts in general yeah
almost eight years now damn that's like
oh gee yeah almost a decade yeah
well [ __ ] eight was yeah it was way
before it was popular then
yeah when when the first podcast ever
did was firing the kid with uh brian
cowan we
we did that before everyone's freaking
stepmom had a podcast like we were the
kind of the first like duo to do it
because before us it was like
marin and rogan a lot of people as far
as like comedy duo
right like especially with a former
athlete in a comic we're like the first
now there's
there's a ton man and they're great too
like you were telling me how when you
first
um when you first got into it you know
you said uh
briefly in the gym i forgot you you said
that like you
uh but when i was fighting yeah yeah
yeah
you got more interaction yeah like i was
going i remember i was fighting andre
olofsky and then
especially at the time there wasn't a
reebok deal in the ufc so i was always
the guy that made a lot of money off
endorsements and then me and brian would
uh start doing podcast merch i made an
abbott kinney fight club shirt
it was like a wild card boxing shirt but
said abbott kenny with a coffee cup on
it right fight club you look ridiculous
and
kenny if you've never been in california
it's like the most like
posh neighborhood so it's a fight club
in this posh neighborhood that we just
made up
and it was a group of comics that we
always hung around and got coffee yeah
i'm like over that kenny fight club
so i made that shirt and then my manager
was like okay i got you this deal for 50
grand for echo or
venom or something i'm like i'm not
gonna do that i'm gonna rock my own [ __ ]
and he's like i feel like it's a bad
idea i'm like
nah i'm gonna rock my own [ __ ] man [ __ ]
it and then i was like the first one to
rock my own shirt and then i walked out
and those shirts [ __ ] flew off the
show
damn so yeah cause you were telling me
you got more like you got more almost
like
engagement from like your audience of
people who are watching they're
interested in you from like podcasting
than you did from fighting
yeah i had no clue you know the hats off
to brian because he was the one he was
the one that wanted to do the podcast
and then
yeah i was going to the airport to
vancouver to fight andre alaska in the
tsa
was like oh what's up big brother call
me like nicknames from the podcast not
fighting
like oh what's up big brown oh what's up
big boy and i'm like what
that's so and they're like what are you
doing here i'm like well
don't you know like i'm going look at my
social media i'm going to fight andre or
lobster
like for real like yeah how do you know
me like oh we're finally kid fans man
i'm like
what yeah so there's crazy it's just
starting to like i'm like oh man i
this this might be what i need to do
yeah focus on yeah
and did you and then you did you like
just focus on it fully or you were like
i was like one foot in one but i was
always like
you know i don't fighters really weren't
doing i was talking about the
the process of like training camp and
the nerves and the guy who was fighting
like on the podcast leading up to the
fight
okay so then people were rallying behind
me because they were listening to me on
this instead of just
a countdown video which i did those but
they would listen to this
so they cared more about me makes sense
and then
yeah and then eventually you know again
it's early stage of podcasting even
checks from advertising on the podcast
i i you know i got beat up by travis
brown my last fight
and then i got the check for getting
punched in the face and i got the check
for being funny on the podcast i was
like
well this one's bigger
i want to do this yeah i'll see you
later yeah that makes sense
yeah it's just it's crazy man crazy
thank god
you you've always wanted to own a gym
yeah man since i was a kid i didn't
think it was gonna be like truthfully
when i first
was opening this gym i was opening this
shim zoo culture because
i was getting kicked out of other gyms
because the kind of content i was
filming was just kind of like
random or like you know i was lifting
girls i was doing kind of crazy [ __ ] and
i would get kicked out of gyms a lot
and so i started to get a big social
media following and i was like i'm going
to open a gym
and originally when i was a kid i
thought i was going to open a gym and
open like just a training studio because
i didn't know that
social media was going to be a thing
when i was growing up it wasn't a thing
right
yeah i'm 31 so when i was like 15 16 17
i thought
oh i'm going to like i want to maybe
move to la and like train celebrities
and like have like a box maybe like a
little bit bigger than this
private studio and train people yeah and
then
um over the years of like doing social
media and like
engaging interacting like in person and
online but mostly from in person like
going to these big conventions expos and
meeting people and talking to people
and realizing like because i was kind of
unique in that i didn't just make
fitness content i was like work out and
do these sets and reps i kind of made
content where i would talk a little bit
more about like my life and where i've
been in my past and my childhood
and like how it's kind of gotten me to
where i was at that time then when i was
making the content then
i haven't done as much of it in the past
like years maybe two years but i do it's
every so often to talk about where i'm
at currently but um
i basically got to the point where i was
talking to people in person i was like
well these people
when they would go like there'd be like
massive lines when i go to like the
arnold
olympia like i would stand there all day
and take photos for like hours
the lines would be like miles long yeah
and um
i realized like the reason why people
really [ __ ] with me was it wasn't
necessarily because like i was like
no they were cool they were like we saw
that but then like i saw this video and
you
you know i didn't kill myself because
you the way you talked about this yeah
there's something in them that they see
in you
and you've gotten to this certain point
yeah that's why they [ __ ] with you so
the reason why i'm bringing it up is
because
i was like i'm gonna open a gym to make
content and just for that like i was
really going to open up that space just
to shoot my own content because i was
getting kicked out of other gyms and to
like invite influencers to shoot content
with me
and then i was like why don't i just
open up because i realized like how i
got there was because of all these
people who had supported me over the
years i was like i want to have a place
where i can meet them
and then it was like for like two and a
half years straight like people there
ever it's still today
but i remember for like two and a half
years straight every day there was
someone there from like
north dakota china wisconsin australia
to talk to me yeah yeah to like to just
come in
because someone it was a i can't
remember the dude's name and i feel bad
but it was someone from
canada that reached out to me about your
gym
that's how i found out about it with
someone yeah someone from canada
was like yo you need to check out this
gym yeah and it and i think the person
was a
was also like into bodybuilding and
stuff and he was like yo if you guys are
looking
for something in in l.a because that's
what we were talking about the whole
time it's like
we just got to work out at home or
something like that and then you know
his name shout out to that guy gosh
i got it right i gotta find it and he'll
he'll he listens to the pod so he'll
probably reach out to me think
about it about like probably three four
months ago chappelle's like i gotta do
something man i have weights on my house
i gave him one kettlebell yeah
[Applause]
that's it so i was just doing the
deadlift like five times a week what i
wanted to say was like
the thing yeah like knowing your story
knowing about you
that's what i thought was cool like you
know you used like
these traumatic things in your life to
push you
and i'm i've always been inspired by
stuff like that because you know
i mean you have a similar story similar
story so it's like oh damn
it's like like when you see someone
especially because i'm not
too familiar with the workout world and
then
you know to jump into it yeah it is a
little intimidating even though yeah i'm
a bigger dude and
you know people just think i could just
naturally do but it it still is a little
intimidating of course
so but like you know to hear your story
and learn about you
like it's just like oh now i have this
like you know
comfort and you know i feel a lot more
comfortable to to go in and
like do something i don't feel like you
know what it represents yeah exactly i
told chappelle once i looked you up i
was like hey you know and
this isn't a mean way i was like hey you
know he didn't he he grew up without a
dad man
smells like well i'm like yeah man yeah
yeah yeah so you know chappelle did too
so there's like you know the i don't
think uh you know it's
that's a special shitty state fraternity
well you guys you know growing up
without a father's is definitely a
special fraternity you know i can't
imagine
so you know but to see someone that like
succeeds after 60 because
that's a rarity like you know like not
too many people
make it out of that you know what i mean
people it's a it's a [ __ ] rarity
so to see someone with the success you
know doing it
it's just it's just dope yeah it's just
[ __ ] dope yeah it's
i mean i'm grateful man um it's crazy
because like i i i'm not trying to get
emotional but i talked about it
i don't i don't know how i didn't know
enough i don't know how your dad you
didn't you just didn't grow up without a
father
he was in prison okay yeah um so my
obviously my circumstance a little
different like my father took his life
when i was young when i was six
and it's crazy because when i think
about it like oh [ __ ] you good brother
it was almost like
[ __ ] um you know how you say most people
don't make it out of it yeah um
[ __ ] man it's okay bro it was a it was
almost as if kind of like
i didn't because like when you think
about a father figure your father
figured someone who like leads you right
shows you like no i'm feeling it yeah me
too
oh yeah it shows you it shows you where
to go yeah he's like a leader
yeah yeah so for some reason i don't
know when i was really young like
i i always thought so much about like
what i wanted to do with my life and
where i wanted to go
like because i was so caught up in like
what happened to my father and like why
like why did he do that because of the
way he passed
um and it
it started me very early on thinking
about my life and like what
like i said what i wanted to do who i
wanted to be and also got me kind of
like
a little bit scared and afraid of death
and it's been like a big anxiety in my
life my whole life but
the the beautiful thing that i learned
out of all this from spending so much
time thinking about like what did i want
to do
um was that i at the same time i
realized i didn't have the guidance
i realized that i didn't i was there was
no box there was no like there's no
difference
there was like this is what you should
do i didn't have someone saying because
my mom always really trusted me to make
good decisions
because for a whole host of reasons i
guess i was just a kid making
good decisions i mean i made a lot of
dumb ones as well but she trusts me to
make decisions and that allowed me
at least my perspective to see where
like no one kind of told me
what to do even though a lot of times in
my life i was looking like i was looking
for like coaches and like
friends parents and yeah older older
older mentors like when i first got in
the gym and really fell in love with the
gym
someone that i met when i was 17 and i
was like i
really like deeply fell in love with
training because like there was a person
there who like
was like a father figure to me who
pushed me who taught me a lot who helped
me get stronger helped me get better in
the gym
and that's when i was like okay this is
this is like this is what i want to do
right but i think if i had a parent i'm
not saying
you know it's great to have a parent
it's great to have a role model um
i think my biggest blessing was being
able to see it differently than like why
me and more like
okay like let me figure this out for
myself and i don't there's no structure
to where or who or what i have to be i
can just do it what makes me happy and
you have to figure it out on your own
so so yeah i mean like that could be a
good thing it could be a bad thing
i just try to make it a good thing and i
and i tried to look for influence like i
said in coaches and football and like
sports or like i said friends and
friends family members and and use that
to like
kind of like teach myself what i wasn't
being taught otherwise right
and you have brothers and sisters yeah
so i have a i have a brother
i have a step-brother and a step-sister
and i have a stepfather
he's a great person he was just is a
little bit of a distant relationship
it wasn't like uh you know how old how
old uh
were you when your mom married him that
was like two
year a year and a half or two years
after my father passed away it's tough
so but there wasn't like great man great
great person
it just wasn't oh it wasn't super close
because you know i mean he had his kids
and like he was focused on this and he i
know he had issues like
their stepmom and like all this stuff so
there was a like a lot going on um
but again great great human just it
wasn't ever like
super close and that's just kind of his
character as a human yeah you know
yeah he wasn't very like oh let me show
you how and this and that because
father and son and i was also like six
seven like
you know i'm getting older six seven
eight so it's like maybe he came in it
was like a
different dynamic than if i was like two
yeah yeah yeah and he also has his own
kids to focus on yeah
yeah but we didn't know what to do but
man like the crazy thing though like
this whole story that i'm telling you
like i i was able to
i truly believe now like it took me
years and years to to realize this like
20 years basically because i realized
this when i was 26 31 now but
it's like right when all my stuff
started to really take off and like i
said i talked to these people at expos
that's when it really clicked and i was
like oh all this [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
that i went through like it made sense
now
yeah yeah so no it's tough man
yeah it's still tough to talk about i
apologize no no you don't apologize
it's just like this is what we do no i
can't imagine you talk about how you're
scared of death and stuff
i think again it's [ __ ] awful and so
traumatic what happened to you when you
in your father
but i think it's also a blessing that
you realize you know how fragile life is
for you know for me it didn't didn't
happen until i had kids
then you're the world's terrifying dude
terrifying
yeah and for you you learned that lesson
unfortunately super early on
yeah yeah i just remember like did i
would think about that [ __ ] like every
day
yep yeah i remember i'd be very like i'd
have friends and and of course but like
i'd
i'd like walk to school and i would like
just spend time every morning like
just like replaying this [ __ ] in my head
like what's the point of this like why
am i here like how am i gonna die like i
was always afraid of it
and uh yeah it still sucked with me
today but
i mean ultimately like i'm grateful for
everything and i just remind myself more
and more and i've learned more and more
over the years like it's just about
like the our time here is just about
this
yes it's like sharing giving
relationships yes
because there's there's nothing like you
know say you've got all the money in the
world you have everything in the world
all the cars everything and it's like
and then you die like you're the thing
that lives on is like how someone
remembered you or the thing that you
taught at things you showed someone else
i think you're gonna be a beast of a
papa too man once you eventually do have
kids you know
i can't wait yeah yeah are you so
positive
i mean i'm probably saying we talked for
an hour
i know right yeah yeah we're basically
the same guy
he's just in way better shape bro i'm
looking at that i'm like
i got a question for you you know you
know that mean where spider-man's like
dude
you're talking
just immediate yeah yeah it's good it's
good vibes where are you from bro
san francisco san francisco yeah i love
it up there yeah
born and raised born and raised yeah
okay i went to all boys high schools
reardon archbishop reardon how was that
the city it was different
yeah but then i didn't i didn't know
anything else right like yeah it's not
like i went to a regular house
but you i saw pictures of you when you
were young you weren't like a big like i
wouldn't be like oh he's a genetic
freak oh i was like now i'm like oh he's
genetic freaks yeah i was skinny
yeah you're a skinny dude yeah tall
skinny yeah and then you just started
working
like you got in the body like basic body
buildings type of bodybuilding like
you're in what the physique yeah i was i
did like the first physique shows in
2011 like when it first came out now
it's popping but back then
you were the guy in board shorts yeah
like right when it first came out
and then and so so you guys know like
they're not on the bible where there was
like you know when you think of bible
you think of mr olympia
well there's others like there's
different levels yeah there's different
categories
yeah so there's like physique where
they're not like
like if you think of like ronnie
coleman's not physique that's mr olympia
when they're like
beefy yeah bodybuilding classic physique
now
men's physique um and then like bikini i
know they canceled a lot of classes i'm
not sure if they still do the women's
like bodybuilding i think it's women's
fitness yeah there's like different
basically like different levels of like
muscularity
okay like more or less yeah yeah i guess
so yeah that was fun competing was fun
yeah it's a beast though right like
again my uncle was in it and it's like
uh
the discipline and the food and then you
know cutting weight
to get there i'm like why are you doing
this yeah like
why are you eating one chicken breast
every day yeah the
crazy thing when i when i think about
this whole the whole like the thing
we're talking about even with my father
right like it permeated like everything
that i did like the reason i got so
like like in love with weight training
and like that feeling and then like
obviously then the outcome was because
it was it was an escape
like straight up like training like when
i was training it's like everything else
would disappear yeah you got to focus
you know if you're under the bench press
says 300 pounds or however much weight
is heavy where it's like you can't think
about
i can't think about death i can't think
about it i can't think about the issues
i'm just doing this so i was like i
wanted to always do more of that
and that's why i found myself like i
would spend like eight hours in the gym
making no money like it wasn't my living
it wasn't what i just like that's where
i love to be because
those are the people that i love the
people that i love to have conversations
with and that's where i felt like i was
able to at the same time
avoid my problems yeah yeah that makes
sense so now it's like now i try and be
more
uh conscious of it and and like not
avoid the problems like go into them
think about them talk about them share
them like
address yeah that's that's the thing too
yeah when i was younger it was all about
like let me avoid this by doing this
and obviously it benefited me positively
now um
and i'm just glad i didn't choose
something else you know yeah
chappelle growing up with your father
you didn't like you were you mad like i
know obviously you had your
yeah you're sober now but you know yes
is your father
passed no no he uh we didn't i didn't
connect with him until i was 29 years
old
i'm 30 i'm 34 now yeah but uh you know
yeah it was because
you know i grew up with an abusive
stepfather so like
you know i was like wondering where my
dad was and you know
i'm like that yeah i was mad that i was
like well this isn't my dad you got two
shitty hands
two shitty hands you know and then
eventually i was i was adopted into
uh a white family it's the greatest
picture of all time the greatest picture
world
do you have that chance it's the
greatest page
it looks photoshopped this is the widest
i've ever seen
in the chapel in the middle it's the
best picture of all time she should be
on like a macy's catalogue yeah it
doesn't look like it's
a catalog but uh you know yeah i was
just
you know you know because it's weird and
great i give
major major props to my adoptive father
you know he
you know taught me a lot but at the same
time that there's just this feeling of
like
you know this ain't my dad you know yeah
and i was holding on to that
a lot you know like like i got this
stepfather that's abusive
you know and then i get out of that
situation and then you know i'm just
like i'm bouncing to these situations
except for with my dad yeah you know
what i mean but
you know through you know
just just finding that positive mindset
you know i had to go through
i had three different anger management
teachers that i had to go through
um to to get a solid understanding of
like where i was and
you know i when i when i found out about
what my father
did in his past like the gang banging
and the drug dealing
you know and you know also and then at
the same time i lost my brother to
to prescription drugs so it's like wow
you know my dad came from that world
i could easily just wrote him off you
know what i mean i could have easily
just been like
nah but there was something that just
that just told me to [ __ ]
go do it just just like [ __ ] jump in
there and just
just it you it's like what do you got to
lose you know i haven't been around him
like if
if he if he's not in my life i'm so used
to him not being there so it's like
what do i got to lose and he's a better
person oh way better he comes
like when we perform uh phoenix or
wherever if you eat we even have him on
my other show king of sting like yeah
he's a good dude he's a good dude
but a lot of people are not willing to
like make that because it's more it's
easier to be like nah [ __ ] this i'm not
going to deal with it
yeah because the harder thing is to deal
with it but yeah
i also think with chappelle too it's
like when other comics whoever complain
about something i'm like [ __ ] do you
know chappelle lacy
the [ __ ] he's been through to make
you're talking about a guy who
just sold out his own shows yeah that's
[ __ ] lit
[ __ ] dope kind of crazy damn man
that's a big move bro that's [ __ ]
yeah that's amazing you came a long way
straight up yeah it's beautiful man it's
in austin texas this friday and saturday
ladies and gentlemen back on his grind
yeah that's so it should work you know
like q is my feature for a while now and
then
you know headline his own shows man
that's why are we crying today
well it's one of those days it's [ __ ]
it's raining out
it's raining it's raining all morning
[ __ ]
[Applause]
my parents love the [ __ ] out of me
sorry for all the times
now to malik what uh he claims
back in january oh yeah listen to this
[ __ ] i can't wait for you to come in
now you're quietly impressed right now
yeah they rode they rode with me man i
love it i love the youngest one i love
the youngest one
oh no that's my baby yeah that's cool
baby sister
you still talking a lot all the time man
all the time
yeah like now i just feel like i just
got you know just a big ass family you
know what i mean like
all like reconnected with my biological
father
made me you know think about things like
with my mama you know i for the longest
time i blamed her
for um you know being with my stepfather
but but i was so 50 50 with her because
i was like
man you know what like but she was not
she's never been mean to me
you know what i mean so it was like this
it's like she's with this shitty dude
she's never been yeah she's never been
mean to me and she was always good to me
but i i it was you talk to her about it
yeah she you
say she stayed obviously easier said
than done yeah
you know he he was he made her feel like
she had to be with him she couldn't get
out yes yeah that's the crazy thing
i mean just in life in general like it's
it's if you're in a situation like that
yeah it's very easy to just speak from
like oh this here's where i'm at and
this is how i feel
without understanding like truly why
someone else made a decision like for
example
my father yeah because i was always in
my head i'm like why did he do this like
why did he do this yeah why did he do
this to my family why did he do this to
my brother my mom
and it's like he dealt with a bunch of
other [ __ ]
in his own life that like i can't even
relate to right and that got him to that
point
was it was he in some dark arts yeah i
know i know that he
had severe depression like like
physically severe depression
clinically depression like exactly like
where like you have like no dopamine and
back then
it was just like oh he's sad it's like
no there's a reason dude yeah yeah
like legit like real depression and then
i know he he did he abused drugs like a
lot of drugs yeah
so um obviously you end up there and you
know but the crazy thing the thing that
i mean i'm kind of derailing this the
point but um when the
and this kind of made me sad but when he
when he actually took his life
he was out he was sober yeah like stone
soap but he must have suppression must
have been that bad
see i feel and i'm not speaking for you
because obviously i've never gone
through this my dad
was around but to me i would almost feel
better knowing that he was
sober because it wasn't a decision he
made under the influence
yeah that was his decision yeah and by
you know and he was
he was of right frame of mind to make it
happen it wasn't like he got all high
and was tweaking out and then [ __ ] up
it was like he
straight up made that decision it's
crazy to hang yourself that was a crazy
decision
like in my mind i'm like how the [ __ ]
like that's like
yeah you think about it it's like what
you can't even it's like what
yeah how did your brother deal with it
because i see um
yeah yeah so my brother he i think he
he wasn't as vocal like a was sharing it
older or younger older
yeah yeah sometimes one year sometimes
two depending on the time of years born
in december
um i think he it was harder for him to
like move past i know now he's he's
he's great i know he's amazing like he
jacked no he's very opposite of me he's
shorter he's skinnier like he's a hippie
like he lives in his van
i love my brother he enjoys life man
yeah
sends me he like basically lives in
tahoe in his van and skis
all day like oh [ __ ] it yeah he loves
nice life yeah it's amazing but what i
was saying was like
it's it's you know talking about your
father and speaking about my my
perception of mine like why did they do
this
it's like there's so much more that
could have led to that and it's so easy
in life for people to be like
someone affects you and then you're just
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] that person [ __ ] you
for what you did and it's like
it's just not that simple yeah well i
feel i feel the same way even with my
stepfather like i look at his life and i
go
you know you know because sometimes i'll
do jokes about it because i've
just worked my ass off to [ __ ] be
comfortable to speak about it
yeah and you know i remember when i
first started doing jokes about it
i remember i sounded i still sounded mad
and i was like how do i get out of that
so i i took this deep dive and i
you know and i looked at his life i
looked at the way he grew up
he didn't grow up great he was doing
exactly what he knew that's all he knows
that's all he knows right
you know what i mean and so i i mean my
siblings they'll still get mad because
he
you know so i have a brother with
special needs so my mom and him still
have to see each other
you know uh from time to time to like
you know help him out with stuff
and you know he'll say things like you
know that he was a good father
well in in my siblings they get mad and
i go
no you can't get mad you got to realize
he really does think that
because his father wasn't around he was
he was there and and granted yeah i'm
not i'm not trying to make an excuse for
like what what the [ __ ] he did
but like you got to realize where his
mind is yeah you have to kind of
drop to his mind to understand like this
is what he's thinking it's not it's not
crazy that he's saying it yeah you know
because his environment
is completely it's just you've got a lot
of work to get there though
oh i'd hit 25
i completely forgive him like i don't i
don't have a grudge and
it feels great it feels great that i can
walk through yeah
life knowing that you know what i mean
it's it's just crazy though you got
there because you you went into it it's
easier to avoid it and then you just
have that grudge your whole life that
bad
like encouraging people like yo like
it's not going to be easy but you need
to like
go inside you got to do the work you
can't just do the workout dude as soon
as you take that full step in that [ __ ]
like you're
you're rolling yeah but your other
family members haven't
uh no you know they're actually doing a
lot better you know
um mainly just talking to me yeah
because they hear they hear another side
because
you know they didn't they didn't get the
luxury of you know being adopted into
a good loving family they stayed up they
stayed in it
you know what i mean like they they had
no choice you know so like and that
like i felt bad for that like i'm like
man i'm with this nice ass family and
yeah you know with my my brothers yeah
oh
big [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
but you know
knowing how our my relationship is with
my siblings now
like it's like oh like they've always
like loved me and like you know
because i didn't know if they did or not
i thought they like [ __ ] resented you
oh yeah because you're sending pictures
of like
tuna casserole and [ __ ] and then they're
like dude like we're having chairs and
water
cheers
no they're all flexing on
dude i told him i said dude i can't wait
for brilliant even if you're running all
the gear in the world it'd be
[ __ ] impossible to gain 40 guys
bradley listen i'm 29 years old okay
i was boxing all my life i know
something about weight you can tell
um i told him he can't come into the gym
you gotta be you gotta be two something
to do so that's that's mine until you
hit 200.
i got a whole i got a whole coat of
ectomorphs out there they like
i'm inspiring them right don't even give
them that merch until you hit 200.
you can't
culture you're like what the [ __ ] that's
the real one i'm 190 right now
like actually solid like if you got on a
scale i got but we bought the scale i
was 182. like that was but you
in january you were not 150. i was i won
153
dude if you were 150 i would have
clowned the [ __ ]
because we're going on this in january
10 i'm going to see you in a minute
you're so skinny
oh my god okay okay i'll tell you i'm
six too yeah you'd better
you know spin that is that i don't think
okay okay i was 150 here it is right
here you can't tell me
dude you look exactly the same don't i
look bigger
pull up right here don't look how skinny
i was and look look at the date that's
you see what i'm saying yeah but they
got skinny you're not 40 pounds
the before i took it he he did hit 225
10 times
bradley i did see him do that 25 yeah
yeah they don't believe me that was 182.
wow i love how bradley has acted like
it's good weight oh
listen again i don't live but i don't
know about this weight thing no it's not
that's not right are you serious two
months
realize who you're talking to right now
40 pounds 40 pounds tell him
right now i was 153 now i'm 190.
currently right now
190. so that's 10 pounds i'm tens of
hours away to come into your gym
yeah we'll see
i think what else is dope about your gym
and one one of the
literally the original reason i went in
hey i knew you were doing your thing
but then also you kind of fighting back
against the city
yeah and you know they're trying to you
know in la for those who don't live in
l.a
they shut down all gyms all gyms except
for zoo gym
cause you fought back yeah how has your
experience been with that
because it's a beast man like i'm sure
you're fighting the good fight i think
yeah because obviously one way to beat
covet is be healthy
it just promotes health and there's no
outbreaks and it's
it's a tricky thing yeah it's crazy
right now because like
there now there's all these studies
coming out too about how like like 63
percent of people who like actually
ended up
you know dying from kovid like are is
more like directly related to
health and exercise yeah not doing so
yep underlying healthy questions
and like like legit studies coming out
saying like we should have encouraged
people to do that
instead of not do that but dude i got a
ticket for riding my bike
yeah i mean listen with this it sucks
it's like i can't say so much but i can
say like
i definitely you don't have to yeah i i
definitely
it's not right what they're doing
because i mean we've spoken about this
man and it's just
uh this is my simple thing like i really
just want to stand up and i want to talk
to the judge i want to talk to the jury
i want to ask him like
if because we might end up getting there
i might go to like a jury trial
i think what's interesting is you're
fighting this fight you're fighting the
good fight
but by the time it gets to that
everything's in the open yeah who are
they fighting for
that point yeah you know what i'm saying
like and then texas opened today yeah
and you've got mississippi
wide open [ __ ] newsom is that he's
like
that's reckless he's like reckless like
well because he but
he let's chill out but no newsome can't
backtrack now like he has to double down
on that's why
everybody's business but this is like
[ __ ] i just want to make this this this
the cigarette thing we'll go ahead yeah
this is the thing that i don't
understand right
if we as humans individuals we can make
the choice
because i don't want to talk about
alcohol because everyone's going to be
like well alcohol people are alcohol
dependent if you take alcohol away from
them they'll die and
because you if you were an alcoholic and
you were dependent on alcohol and
someone took it away from you
you die yeah like years of alcohol abuse
to like take it away you have a heart
attack you your body's wrong
granted everyone else who's not alcohol
dependent
then maybe they don't need to go get
alcohol like if we're trying to
determine what's good for people in the
public health right because the public
health officials are telling me that
my gym is a problem by telling me it
should be closed right
but at the same time like can you can
they also explain to me
there's two things i want to talk about
why is it okay for us to make decisions
as individuals to go
buy cigarettes that cause
like the three things that are making
people die of complications with cover
like most people who die from covet are
dying because of covin
but because of these three other
conditions which is high blood pressure
diabetes and cholesterol heart disease
right and those which facts those are
effects those are likely and
that's the thing i'm pretty sure you
would like you that a person that runs a
gym
a facility where people to go people go
to work on their health
i'm pretty sure you would look up as
much statistics as you could but these
are facts yeah
yeah i'm not saying like these are these
are they're like released facts from
the cdc and all these are the things
that are killing people in combination
with covet right
those three things are caused by
cigarettes not only to you smoking them
but to people who around you secondhand
smoke but it's an okay choice
for us to buy that cigarette to smoke it
to kill myself like to cause these
issues the government's giving you that
freedom yeah and him to make that
freedom's okay
but it's not okay for me to make the
choice to go to the gym
to combat those same three things to
defend myself from something that
we don't have a vaccine for in the
beginning right yeah so but it's like
how is how is the health official
telling me that like that's an okay it's
going to make it but this is not an okay
choice like
there is no there is no explanation
there is no rhyme or reason you cannot
make that
it's optics you can't make it your
business shut down for optics here
and then so that's the crazy thing right
because then then it's like we go to
court and i'm looking at other gyms
because there are some gyms who try to
fight back in the same time frame and
like they'll have
10 counts five counts fifth like like
maybe fifteen
of coffee of course i'm not a covet of
it's a eight point seven seven
which is saying like you guys didn't
listen to us you're open
right and then there's other counsel i
have where i didn't let people in right
which is not letting the health
inspector come in right
but i have that we're not listening
count eight point seven seven
i have like i think like 60 or 70 of
them now and other gyms have like five
four you're also the most famous so
that's the thing right they're gonna
they're trying to make an example
if they do it to you they're like these
other you you other gym owners are
smaller but
bradley for sure look what happened to
him and you're smaller but here's the
interesting thing right
but at the same time in the same county
production
what we're doing here is okay indoors
and it's it's deemed essential
because it's entertainment right so if
the same at this like
the way that i built that entire thing
was through this right it's through
entertainment they're like
millions of views on social media and
all this stuff right so at the same time
that they're attacking me
for what i'm like also should be
considered essential for correct
right it's just it doesn't like and i've
to your defense i've never
seen a gym with more content creators
than zoo culture there's
so many cameras yeah oh yeah everyone
has their own [ __ ] channel
yeah everyone i mean there's literally
like hey mutombo out of the way i'm like
what and then
yeah but so so yeah we have like there's
tons of people who travel from all over
to shoot content all the raw gear
athletes shoot content like everyone who
comes and shoots content
for the same purpose of entertainment
correct and that's considered essential
so i'm just like if they're over here
attacking me like i remember sitting in
court and the ladies like he pros on
social media every day all this like
he's continuing to break these things
and it's like
wait but then on the other hand you guys
are saying that like people who make
content in
facilities indoors is okay but like now
i'm being attacked for the same exact
reason that like you're seeing
see i don't think they realize what
animal they're dealing with you know
what i'm saying they just think oh it's
like a 24 hour fitness or a gold gym
it's like no [ __ ]
it's it's a different what we're doing
is different than those other ones and
it's more of a private gym it's not like
there's just no
a [ __ ] ton of people it's like it might
be busy but it's busy like people doing
specific things yeah so in hindsight
dealing with what you
dealt with would you make the same
stance absolutely
well because it's because financially i
know you know i won't put your business
out there i know it's
got some major products and that's the
thing man what i want to talk about too
like i'll because i'll get comments
we'll be like here
you know you're you're selfish you're an
[ __ ] like close the gym down i'm like
hold on wait a minute i would be selfish
if i closed down my gym and just shot
all my content let all my people come in
to shoot content that was it
because like what about all my [ __ ]
employees who like it's their livelihood
what about the kid who i was when i was
16 17 years old who was like
maybe i might have ended my [ __ ] life
because i didn't have something to do or
that kid can't go to school right now
and
his only outlet is to work out and shoot
content exactly and that's how he
just trained like i was that kid that if
i didn't have the gym i don't know if
i'd be here today
yeah so i'm not gonna take it away from
that kid who like i knew that i
like that was me yeah so there could be
kids in there that i i don't know well
enough maybe i didn't speak to them far
enough like
to maybe that's the position that
they're in or for some reason
posting those comments they don't
realize it's like when i first i was
like when the first comic start torn
during kovid
and i got so much hate and i was like do
you realize when i go into a city that
like houston san antonio
that staff hasn't had any form of income
in
months and when i roll through there
they're getting [ __ ] paid men
they're they're making their rent
they're making their mortgage they're
feeding their kids well let's talk about
this right like
number one there is there is zero actual
spread of covert in my gym there's no no
issue no one's ever come back and said
this no one said their family members
someone i know like no one's ever come
in
but at the same time like if you talk
about money
this that was the thing that really
irked me in the beginning was like look
[ __ ] me [ __ ] zoo culture right
i love look i i love what it is but this
is bigger than that
because what about the thousands of
business owners who
that is their entire livelihood and they
work their whole life to get there
and the government goes you're not
essential good luck so what about
someone's bills medical bills who knows
their kid has cancer maybe they're
paying for chemo like
what about all that stuff so now that
guy's life and his mortgage and his wife
and his family and his kid who's dealing
with this is not
it's just not as important as someone
who could die from covet over here but
that kid can die from cancer
and that guy might kill himself when his
kid dies from cancer and shoot himself
in the [ __ ] head okay
and that so those lives don't matter
like how are you just
how are you deciding what's essential
for someone else yep yeah like that
that's the [ __ ] up part and right when
i saw that and then you start seeing
like
you start reading about how like the
[ __ ] the you know all the big ceos
stepped down sold all their shares when
right before the [ __ ] plummeted
like they knew the [ __ ] was coming all
the shocks going down and then bought
their [ __ ] but like
but like we all like that's okay like
we're we're going to play this game
we're like no
got [ __ ] like that's the [ __ ] up
thing is like i could have closed on my
[ __ ] and just filmed my content been
like
you know [ __ ] this i'm just gonna like
ride this out like i don't because i
didn't need
income the gym has been the biggest
liability in my life for me for sure
lawsuits paying employees all this stuff
i'm paying the most like the most money
comes out of that gym yeah right yeah
i'm not over here banking money on the
gym
and now it's like i could have closed
all that down and made
incurred way less liability but then
it's like what about all the people who
really need it and then
standing for the people who don't stand
and can't stand because they don't have
enough money because the city goes
here's a fine here's a fine here's a
fine clothesline shut them down
yeah and now they're like now their life
is [ __ ] like they're more
everything like their their livelihood
is gone i just felt like
it yeah you'd be fine no matter what
obviously you you're not relying on the
membership at zoo culture you pay your
bills i i think what's interesting is
things start up you know texas
mississippi
florida supposed to happen soon even la
from what i hear is gonna start opening
up more and more and more yeah so by the
time you get to this it's like
what are we arguing now that we have
more facts it's gonna be tough for
what ground they're gonna stand on
because a lot of those things are coming
after you for
we know from science and just just
experience
now through this coveted period that a
lot of that stuff isn't isn't well
there's literally no proof
like how if i go to trial really how are
they going to prove that
there has been ever a problem in the gym
yeah there's no there's no
problem and that's why the city is being
sued by a lot a lot of people
i mean listen i'm not saying that that
i'm not going to be behind that like
yeah i'm going to be there
because i spent three months we operated
with a generator because they came and
literally turned our power off
so we operated the generator every day
for three months so i at least want that
seven grand back a month
that's what they [ __ ] do you know
because we're feeling generous
i know about generators and it's stupid
and you document it all on your youtube
channel too like you going to court
it's funny because you went to i watched
you saw that video you went to court you
came out there's like fans of
[ __ ] cameras and [ __ ] yeah but but
like i i just all these like
super protein bros
i haven't said a lot about it you know
because like i
i don't want to i this is a crazy thing
man when i first started saying this
i just got to say this because you know
what [ __ ] it it just bothers me and i
have to say it sure
when i first started posting like i made
a series of posts talking about how like
you know that the loans came out and
like you know big multi-million dollar
companies got these loans like i think
like
maybe 30 percent of businesses that need
it got the actual loans yeah but then
the actual loans that you got were like
they're only subsidizing like 70 of what
the employees should make
yeah like payroll right but not
utilities not expenses nothing right so
like
imagine your business owner you get this
loan because i i applied for this and i
i read all the things that i i talked to
my account what can i pay for right
i can only pay for 70 of what the
employees should make so imagine i'm a
business owner i pay my employees for
however many months
that is but i can't pay rent mortgage
utilities for of the business or for
myself as an owner
right my situation's different because i
have other sources of income but imagine
you're in that situation where you pay
your employees what business do they
come back to
when you couldn't pay for your rent
utilities yeah yeah so then it's like
it just so i i wrote this whole series
of like
like just factual [ __ ] right on my
instagram nothing like saying like
you know [ __ ] the city because like it's
not about that i was just like this is
what's happening to me like help me make
this make sense i think you pulled it up
on a thing like you pulled a tweet up
yeah i pulled i posted that tweet like
in one of the other podcasts you did and
then i posted like a few like black
screens on instagram where i was just
writing these things like
like you know we're all focusing on this
but like when no one's talking about all
this other stuff like the
the ancillary damage that happens
because of it right and just speaking
like kind of like
just not general specific but not
attacking and then
how come i hear from like my my lawyer
at the time otherwise at the time that
the district attorney or like the
prosecutor like saw that and was mad
so it's like wait wait wait like what
are we like so like now i can't i can't
you guys don't want me to like speak
voices
like the first amendment yeah yeah like
so now that's a problem to you guys
because i'm saying these things like
it's just like where
what the [ __ ] is going on like what's
happening like i'm not saying anything
i'm not saying [ __ ] you guys you guys
suck i'm just saying like this is wrong
why is this happening yeah explain it to
me
yeah like and then another thing like
the whole gyms with the you know the
gyms where they're like yo
as long as it's outside but then they
just put it inside some like basically
like saran wrap with like less
filtration
that's okay it's like what do you guys
think like
and i'm i'm like what scientists told
you that like that was the right amount
of airflow like how are you determining
that what's outside but even though it's
inside what's the airflow like yeah
who's saying that like that is like show
me that data
i think it's really interesting as you
go through this what leg they're gonna
stand on yeah i just
shot like show me the problem in my gym
show me the data saying that jim's like
there's data proving otherwise
like so what like why what's happening
just because you said so
yeah are they still trying to censor you
well i'm doing my best to like
not go out there and say all this crazy
[ __ ] until you get through it until i
get through it yeah cause like there's
so much more i want to say man but it's
just like
[ __ ] it's like what what's happening
like i'm just so confused
i like if they man you're fighting the
good fight brother yeah yeah
i just feel this i just feel this if
they were really serious about coat
being a really big issue like if it was
as big of an issue as they've made it
out to be then why do they continue let
people fly and pack planes
i i look i get it like because it's this
is protected i know i've read about all
this i was protected by like a federal
thing like they're okay to do it because
it's federal but it's like
but if we're talking about public health
then why is that continuing why did that
continue the whole time
money my man like that's a that's
exactly yeah we travel all the time
and that's the thing it's just like
that's the thing it's just like i know
what it is but like
i don't what i don't understand is how
people don't realize that
because you keep the people who are like
you're bad you don't have a mask on
you're bad your gym is open you're bad
you're this and
everyone's just dividing and attacking
each other and it's like wait you guys
cannot see all this writing on the wall
like
what about that like you guys are you're
not you're okay with that happening
because
they didn't say it was a big problem or
like yeah they're they're writing all
these articles saying like no it's
actually really safe and all this
yeah i'm in the tubes when i go to a
restaurant i got to put a mask on and
then
when i stand up to go to the bathroom
but when i sit down and have this in my
hand all the time
i can't give you cold it's all good yeah
help me make this make sense yeah and it
just
it doesn't again it's gonna be
interesting once you you know finally
get through it man yeah
yeah good sorry i should get something
no i don't know yeah actually
no i'm censoring myself i'll pop off man
uh what do you got jen you like the jim
robin hood
okay so this is for you a bunch of
people have been sending this
in the vp of nike here
in northern america had to resign
because they found out that her son
has been ordering shoes with the credit
card that he set up in her name using
her
employee uh connections he would buy
hundreds and hundreds of sneakers then
resell them do you know how much
money this kid was making here's what's
the [ __ ] about this you know uh
ann herbert who was the who worked for
uh nike
you know she's making like three four
million a year like i don't know why she
did this
but i'm confused so was he actually
getting shoes
from official nike or was he just buying
nike's yeah but was he using her
discount yes like
oh wow yes so uh the story officially as
of now
is that she resign uh she resigned
shortly after they found out because he
was actually
having an interview done with a popular
like shoe publication
and he ended up speaking a little too
loosely
and he revealed who his mom was when
they started fishing into
wow who like how he got off his
connections they realized that
she's been working for nike for 25 years
so he snitched on himself
yeah he basically snitched on himself
well this is obvious he wasn't he didn't
move smart either he had
six pairs of nike mags yes you know
he was very very vocal about how he has
all these shoes and he's like the plug
he was loud about it yeah he was very
loud about it but nobody knew who his
mom was they didn't know how he was
getting these shoes
and so when he did the interview he
accidentally outed his mom
and then he tried to get the publication
to not publish her name and his
connections
they then found out that he actually
signed up for a credit card under his
mother's name
and then used her name her connections
and all the information
he knows about her work stuff to then
get these shoes he would get
hundreds and hundreds he spent 132 grand
one morning for a launch of kanye west
sneakers
how long did this go on for a few years
he is currently
19 so we don't know exactly how long
he's been doing this for well
i wanted to face for a reason why i'm
taking else on this nike app
everyone's so mad i never went on that
sneaker app
from somebody else from a plug or
something like that i take somebody else
on that [ __ ] nike yeah who's talking
about that in the
like there's no like how do you but if
you have all your access to your mom's
like
yeah but at some point when that person
the supplier who's giving you should be
like wait a [ __ ] minute
yes how come he was never going back to
nike like yo they're doing it yeah
there's a few people like
you you know yeah why does jeremy want
eight nike mags
yeah shoe that soldier he could he could
have been great he could have been
paying them off
yeah there's others i don't know there's
other people taking that but also that
mom was making
four million a year salary yeah so she
had the responsibility
to resign yeah it's terrible people
think that she resign
she resigns so quickly and so quietly
because there's more that will come out
that she's worried they're gonna find
out because people are speculating that
like when she found out she was just
like oh i'm sorry
like my son did this it's wrong but i'm
gonna step down for the
better of the company people think that
she's trying to cover up something else
like maybe he did something else even
worse with all of her information
for nike so it's still there's an
investigation going on but damn well
hopefully this means i'll win shoes next
week
and this week we should pray what else
you have
okay so um a oregon
judge has recently ruled that miss
america
the actual pageant competition can now
say that only natural born females are
able to be in the pageant
because there was a transgender uh
beauty queen in oregon who wanted to
then
compete to eventually try to compete for
the title she's prettier than these
natural born women who gives a [ __ ] uh
like if it's that girl from vegas stevie
showed up
sounds like something she'd have to go
through like a lot more yeah
dude she was born a dude and then you
know she's just crashing down she
becomes miss america i mean yeah
wow uh i think you can find it i don't
have it in this article
i need to know that that's where she
she'd been she better not be bad
it looks like me with a wig
hmm that's that's oregon that's not
working you're funny
it's not my type i'm in l.a
miss oregon okay
i don't think she was actually miss
oregon she was miss earth oregon it's
like a different
beauty pageant so like miss oregon but
not really oh [ __ ]
beauty pageant yeah what are they so
worried about yeah well she wanted to
compete
and so the organization actually saw her
ain't getting away
from piglet
she ain't gonna win let her compete let
her compete
i've seen those women
but she should have the right to compete
yeah that's [ __ ] who cares if there's
some bad transgender
come on who cares she could she could be
a lot of zoo culture
what else she got
[Laughter]
as you're saying texas uh yesterday
officially announced that they
are 100 open and that there is no longer
going to be a mass mandate now don't get
it twisted it's not like if you fly to
texas right now it's off and pop
everyone's masses off yeah
because all the mayors you know can
decide like austin's
hey tell you austin ain't open so they
can dictate if they're gonna
the state might say hey you don't have
to enforce anything but each mayor can
decide so
the mayor in austin's like nope we're
still using mass we're still half
capacity
you can eat inside so it's not like
people think it's just like oh
it's popping now it's not especially in
austin got it
as i go there this weekend but it's
still better than
here yeah yeah one percent all right
so there is a company who is starting to
uh plan the creation of the first
space hotel and it's plan they're
planning on opening it up
for 2027 anywhere between a
three-day weekend to weekly rentals
or you can buy six years yeah or you can
buy
um like a a room there how do you get
there
a plane a spaceship a spaceship and then
you dock and then you get
[ __ ] that dude
that [ __ ] lit hell yeah no absolutely
not would you
pros cons you ever been to four seasons
in hawaii yeah
i don't need to go to [ __ ] mars to
hang out i can look down at hawaii
at least a few weeks ago it really
depends on
how far the hotel is going to be well no
if it's just
if it's just like floating in orbit yeah
because
mars takes [ __ ] forever yeah that's
why i don't know if it's six months
a few days a few weeks or if it's gonna
be months
as of right now i don't think they're
taking you like way deep into space but
also you know how
it's like even if you get to hawaii and
you got an oceanfront property
like oh damn this is great look at that
beach and then you move on with your
life
you would fly all the way to space all
these
[ __ ] variables then you get there
you're like damn look at the earth from
here like they're just in the room
bro you and your friends like i want to
go home man yeah
you take your girls
and then some dumb ass like opens up a
window or something and we all get
you see people on cruise ships all the
time they fall off the side
you have that idiot yeah it's hot babe
i'm opening up a window
we're using
hell no i'm happy here there's so much
stuff i haven't seen here on
in that's true yeah that is true i've
never been to thailand
[ __ ] mom i heard thailand's great
food oh my lady boys
yeah whatever you were
right now we don't have time to go
everywhere we want to go here yeah so
why go there did i go to school
yeah i'm just all right all right well
you guys talk
i'm up there you guys talked off air
about this but jj watt signing with the
uh
cardinals yeah and then uh i guess
yesterday he signed a two two year deal
for like 31 or potentially 31 million
dollars
good for him man two years two years
yeah two year deals wow
i think he has like two years left you
know yeah
when uh i don't know but three-time uh
defensive player of the year he's a
beast man
oh he's
what is that uh in football it's getting
up there
years oh really yeah yeah he still has
some good time left there's a reason
for his position yeah yeah but he's just
been injure
injury yeah and that defensive line i
can't think of that guy name he's going
to be the
opposite side of him they're going to
have a good squad next year arizona
yeah all right all right you got to get
my arizona yeah
this is an mma one so hamza shamayev
he's like one of the
the more famous up-and-comers he's
pretty brand new right he's killing it
right now
he got he got hot last year because he
took i think like
four fights and like yeah short span
some [ __ ] like fought you kept fighting
kept fighting
and winning star awesome fashion too
yeah he was he was he was like the
mvp of covet fighting like he kept
fighting kept fighting and beating the
show why is it why is he done
so he had kovid and apparently like he
tried many times to like fight it but
then
he's still getting like residual effects
from it so here's what so
so he had covered pulled out of he's
supposed to fight leon edwards
um he they kept postponing the fight he
got kovit
had horrible symptoms from it you know
he's one of the poor guys that have
horrible symptoms
but then they put him this is dana white
speaking yeah for this
they put him on the steroid to help him
with his lung stuff and
apparently it's some crazy steroid that
has horrible
like effects like side effects and they
told him don't work out on it dude
you're gonna feel like [ __ ] but it's
gonna beat this thing
so eventually it can work out obviously
he didn't listen
gets that shot and then tries working
out the next day and felt horrible
so he's like oh this is how i'm gonna
feel i retire he got he on twitter was
like oh i retire i can't fight anymore
but apparently him and dana had a
conversation and danny's like he's not
retiring
he's emotional he'll be fine so he
posted on his instagram how
he just his body's not working the way
the right way because the illness so he
feels like he has to leave the sport
and then dana and i talked to him and
also hamza ramzan khadirov who has like
a crazy history
in chechnya uh he had to talk with him
and then he immediately says i'm back
i think he's just emotionally how it is
he's a monster and then he goes to the
gym and everything's slow and he feels
[ __ ] he's like i can't beat anybody like
this so
yeah he just got him he's also young so
you got emotional how long is this this
like
does this last like covet stuff like
does that because i was reading stuff
about some people get it like it lasts a
while
yeah i think everyone's different man
you think you know a guy who's in good
shape and stuff he'd beat it fast but
apparently it was really bad for him i
don't know if he had
other issues stuff like that you know if
he had pneumonia as a kid
there's a bunch of stuff that goes into
it yeah
but yeah he'll be all right he just got
you don't know when he first got up but
it was probably like a month or two ago
yeah when he got it yeah when he got it
oh and he's been fighting it ever since
oh so it's recent yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah give him some time just like a
month ago he just
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah he'll be fine
guarantee he fights again
all right uh bill burr talking about
gina carano's firing
yeah i heard about this you saw that
yeah you were gone
she was on another party it's a weird
time unless she did some truly horrible
[ __ ] or said
overly racist [ __ ] uh i don't know i
think there's just too many channels and
then
you gotta do sensational [ __ ] i don't
know what the [ __ ] it is
i'm on that [ __ ] show now i gotta
watch the he's just being super honest
about it too yeah she was an absolute
sweetheart
i love bill burr she was an absolute
sweetheart super [ __ ]
super nice [ __ ] a lot of cussing
super nice
uh you know whatever and some how
someone will take this video and they'll
make me say something else and try to
get rid of
my bald action figure it's
[ __ ] crazy times people just waiting
laying in the weeds doug
yeah yeah uh keep going down later in
the podcast bro elaborate on his views
uh cancel culture saying now it's
becoming like hey you made an ignorant
comparison
uh there goes your dream right and i
look at this and it's like who the [ __ ]
stands up to that
yeah he's right yeah it's an interesting
time for sure
yeah yeah that's a culture yeah i love
bill birdman he's great she's one of the
real ones what did she
say does anyone know what she said oh
she yeah he was just a
she was making jokes though like no
she's not jokes
not jokes no not that oh it was that's
what i said that's an old thing she she
compared to what the government was
doing to covet to
the holocaust and she was like there's
similarities like they start with this
they take away this right like
we've seen this over history and people
have made those comparisons but she
posted an actual picture
i think it use you know poor taste and
probably not the smartest thing to do
but lose your
job over it dude yeah and then what's
interesting is the the
the co-host on that on that same
mandalorian show
years prior made us uh something a
similar
comment and he's fine no one [ __ ] with
him but just because she did it during
right now
she got cancelled damn so it's crazy
[ __ ] that show's great too yeah she
actually came out and said that uh
somebody over in disney accidentally
sent her an email saying that they want
to fire her anyways
this is what me and brian we're talking
about so what she did i don't
vouch for it i love gina i think she's a
great human being
and i think it's totally [ __ ] up what
they did to her but
uh i think it was a matter of they're
just waiting to get ready yeah
that's why as soon as they saw this like
yes we got her who knows maybe they want
somebody else for the role maybe she
wasn't
what they thought it was in a fit who
knows but usually
those those studios those networks you
know like
they're going to stand behind so like if
that's daniel day lewis or leonardo
dicaprio i think he'd get fired over
that true
no true shut the [ __ ] up because they're
so talented with her they might have had
someone else in mind for the role
yeah they were just waiting for a little
crack like oh there we go she's out
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
all right uh i saw this on rogan's
instagram
oh yeah you saw this too it's insane so
a cephalopod
it does a cuff cuttlefish i guess it
learned how to do something where they
waited for
they bypassed one treat and waited a
little longer for a better treat
which is what it's a cognitive test for
kids yep and they were able to wait like
50 to 130 seconds
is now is he is that he's a type of like
mollusk is he like an octopus
cephalopods like uh squid octopus yeah
they they say like octopus like when
you're in calamari you [ __ ] think about
this
feel things and like know what's going
on and we're just [ __ ] i feel bad
and jim wants to eat a lot i love them
uh my octopus teacher yeah did you just
say that i think that's what jay was
thinking about
the october's teacher i literally cannot
eat i would never eat oh man that
octopus was like a dog once jay told me
about that my brother jay told me about
that i'm like
i haven't had octopus since did you have
you watched it though
no go watch it it was on netflix yes
it's amazing it's legit dope but it'll
make you feel like that it's a dog
but when i was in hawaii i was uh
snorkeling
and we had like a guy and he went and
grabbed an octopus
and i was like oh dude is he gonna like
be mean to me he's like no he can feel
your intentions
like get the [ __ ] out of here he's like
yeah watch like your friend's real
scared over there and you want to go put
them in the octopus they went back
he's like but you're you know you like
animals and you're loving and put on me
like what's grabbed onto me
oh like so if you watch this it's
literally that like it shows a
progression when you first met him
it's dude they're so cool yeah i don't
touch calamari but you said also
their lifespan is short though right
that's why i feel better about eating
them yeah i think their life stands like
three years or some [ __ ]
so that's crazy once they give i think
once they give uh offspring like they
slowly yeah three
fire years chin and you want it and you
want to [ __ ] eat his face
it's part of my culture if anything
three years should make you not want to
eat them
you only have three years i've got to
watch like very cool you're you're
gonna watch it i have to watch it if i
want to eat it i gotta watch it
yeah all right before i eat another one
i'm watching the documentary thanks
the cephalopod passed a test that like
kids do yeah and they said not all of
them just like regular kids some kids
won't pass it but
the ones that they had in their you know
facility i'd be [ __ ] pissed my kid
didn't beat out the octopus
you know if you give me kids taking a
small treat
with kids they gave them like an apple
but if you wait like 15 minutes we'll
give you this chocolate bar
so a lot of kids you know but they're
smart enough their brains start you know
rolling they'll say oh i want the
chocolates i'll wait
that's been a popular trend on tick tock
a lot of people do that with their kids
they'll set up a camera to film and say
okay
wait until like daddy gets back and you
can get a treat afterwards and there's
like a cupcake in front of them if they
take a bite talk yeah that's dope
like parent talk yeah oh really i'll do
that
i guarantee you tiger won't touch that
cupcake what about boston
you would destroy that thing but he also
you know he's one so
boston tiger beat the shot of an octopus
though he'd beat him into that thing
would you ever do that sliced cheese
thing no were they people yeah they
throw like spices
on their faces falls in their face i
feel like it's humiliating for the kids
people grab like slices like you know
cheddar cheese
and throw it at the kid's face and watch
it fall down they put these kids back
into school what the [ __ ]
hey parents figure some other [ __ ] out
man i think this was like
the cheese challenge before tick tock
just like people on it is that
government cheese
that's just messed up what
this went viral yeah yeah it became a
trend i don't get it
i don't know how is that funny it's
humiliating i think it's just bored
parents that's really what it is so
[ __ ] bored
oh this is pretty pandemic so some kids
cry which is suck
some kids laugh
that's what you want yeah
okay that baby's not cute
i gotta stop it there yeah i don't i
mean i'd never humiliate my kid like
that
i think it's the same type of parents
who do the jimmy kimmel challenge where
it's like oh tell your kids you ate all
their
all their halloween kids and they get
their reaction it's the same thing [ __ ]
no
yeah what else you guys talking with
your kids yeah um let's see uh let this
one here
you always talk about cheeto fingers so
this girl she
she did a home home invasion thing where
she tried i don't know there's a mom and
two kids there
she broke into the window and then she
called the cops and then she booked
this girl booked and then they found a
bag of cheetos on the ground
in a bottle of water so then they found
her after
you know they were looking around the
yard so when they looked at her teeth
she had cheeto resin in her teeth so
they found out that's her that broke
into the house
she did she don't wait cheeto dusk she's
just hanging out in the backyard no she
was hiding
and then when they finally found her she
said but she smelled like cheese yeah
but then they found out
yeah cheetos in her teeth yeah if
they're the crunchy cheetos or the puffs
they stick
oh yeah good looking net off your
fingers that's why i eat cheetos with
chopsticks
i don't want cheeto fingers really yeah
wow i haven't had a cheeto
in forever they're so good but you feel
so shitty after that i like the
the crunchy ones the crunch is there any
healthy i love the spicy ones what about
the jalapenos
there's no healthy cheeto right oh
actually no there's a
cheeto now there's like a brand new uh
like keto snacks like that so there's
like a hot cheeto puff
but then it's keto the uh keto cereal
magic spoon is that good yeah you [ __ ]
with it how's your diet you [ __ ]
magic spoon i i don't do
i don't like i don't i've tried it all
that was aggressive
that's all i want to ask you like i like
more balanced stuff like why so like you
know people like oh i do keto and they
don't eat all like completely they don't
eat there so they don't eat that like
yeah
keto it can be a good diet for a lot of
people though it's just it's hard to
maintain it the longevity i
i did it for months and the longevity i
i don't see how someone can do it for
like years yeah you got to kind of like
really enjoy that food so i i tend to
eat balance like i'll eat the carbs i'll
eat the fat i'll eat the protein
i just like i eat healthy food yeah you
know you do a specific amount of each
in each meal what's a normal meal for
you bradley like we'll see wake up
work out what are you eating apples uh
i'll eat like i'm saying a men's health
interview
yeah no you're trying to see if you know
what i do oh he doesn't eat like
yeah definitely hey let me look nope
yeah i'll eat like uh
i don't know how much rice how much is
in that factory valley you got this man
explaining his
two cups of rice two or three cups of
rice and like two
two bison patties and then like some
spinach like you're fueling your body
yeah yeah like a good but and then i'll
put some like hot sauce or some teriyaki
sauce
yeah like my my get my dietitian uh my
dolce he's like you got it because
he would have carbs and he's like you
need to get out of the mindset that
carbs are the enemy yeah that's he's
like dude
if you have good carbs it fuels
everything you do for sure so like i'll
have like half a cup of white rice or
i'll have a zico bread with avocado in
the morning like
or grains and oats in the morning like
he's like you got to get out of the
mindset that
carbs are the enemy yeah i don't know it
was back to atkins thing was the thing
that started people on this like don't
eat carbs that make you fat thing
yeah and also like don't eat past a
certain time yeah which makes you
none of that actually makes you fat like
eating shitty food often makes correct
fat
yeah and eating more than you should
more often than not is going to make you
fat yep right so
like no problem yeah i mean it's just
eating a balance is always going to make
you feel better
because then you're because like when
people die especially when they cut
calories like
and they're trying to lose weight they
cut out a lot of like nutrients vitamins
and minerals that are like making your
body feel
more efficient making your brain feel
clear and that's why the diets become
like and also like
um your your ability to be full and
satiated
is like not there because you don't have
enough of things to make your brain say
oh i'm good yeah
right so you're constantly like you know
when you cut certain things out of your
diet like carbs you're like
i just want to eat that [ __ ] those
chips you're more likely to break but
when you have more balance it's like
it's more sustainable yeah i've i've had
a balance since i know that
my dolce and i haven't i haven't cheated
and i don't know how i mean
[ __ ] four weeks yeah it's all about
balance because now because the diagrams
are nothing
it's all about consistency yeah man if
you can't be consistent with something
and you do it for a few months and then
you just revert it's like what's the
[ __ ]
point what's the point yeah yeah
disappointed gaining four it should be
like slowly but surely it should be your
thought not like i need to do this in a
month that's a marathon
so it's like that's like people always
like i need to lose weight right now
it's like
start [ __ ] six months ago you know
like so yep
it's just harder that way people like
the quick like yeah it's tough i got you
what you got any more chin you want
anymore are you good
we've done on that one i've got a really
good one it's about
wolves being killed [ __ ] all right
you want to see them yeah walls being
killed yeah yeah so wait wait killed
it was in the new york times uh within
three days what hunters killed over 200
wolves oh i thought it was just one
hunter i was really impressed
but i thought it was one too i'm like
jesus christ yeah but it's still not
that many hunters
i guess because they have to do control
in this area in wisconsin
but they went overboard and they feel
like these guys are just executing them
what the [ __ ] yeah because you know some
hunters just love to kill yeah
some some so they think that's what's
happening so originally they
they like pulled back on the protection
of these wolves
kill a few yeah and these boys just went
hey they went like almost 82 percent
over the killings and now they're back
on an endangered species list
i guess some conservatives conservatives
say that they are but
i don't know how we could actually tell
216 was killed in less than 60 hours
yeah jesus christ those guys are [ __ ]
weapons
wait they they kill him because
everything control yeah for control
because just first people
still have to kill them a certain amount
what do you mean like control
like do they mess up like you don't want
too many yeah you don't want too many in
there because you don't want to make it
also they kill like the big like alpha
wolves because they'll take out the cubs
all the time so you take him out
it allows them to grow you know but they
want you need a certain amount of wolves
there
to kill the amount of deer and whatever
animals there that mess up the
vegetation [ __ ] everywhere yeah
yeah so it's a balance but these guys
just went overboard and killed way too
many
and it made the new york times can you
eat wolf or
nah nah i think you could eat pretty
much anything you can't eat what do you
want to eat wolf not a diet i don't want
to eat it
i don't know about wolves but i've seen
people kill mountain lions and eat them
and they say they're
delicious i think rogan had mountain he
he talks about and i saw it on uh
different articles but that's a cat
yeah what is it what i saw people eat
coyote dog yeah
people eat coyotes yeah people coyotes
yeah yeah you know it's a dog though
canine
yeah yeah that's for dogs you know
coyotes and uh wolf isn't a cat come on
you know
yeah i watched the jungle book yeah okay
they only eat them during times of
scarcity so there are edibles oh so it's
not like
not delicious basie is a dog
that's where dogs come from and some
people love dogs unfortunately
i heard pigs have personalities like
dogs i've heard that too
that's a [ __ ] it's such a moment he's
dead
he's laughing at chapel they thought
wolves were cats
yeah he thought of wolverine i couldn't
like running packs and
so like you're you're an alumni at east
west coast
la county we passed so do you your
teacher's like [ __ ]
where's l.a i
he thinks wolves are cats i went to west
l.a we passed it everything that never
happened uh bradley
we love you man you've changed our lives
dude yeah we love the gym
keep the good fight man i love you bro
yeah man
you don't have him but that's fine so
passionate every time he speaks dude
when you get to 200
i'm in here yeah we'll see what we're
going to see what you look like
i'm 190 we're going to get you i'll talk
to the guys at the gym honestly if i had
a hoodie on
side by side we'll be like a little bit
yeah yeah i hope you get to 200
bro i'm going to get this yeah i got a
whole try damn hecto morse yeah that'd
be dope yeah i believe you get 200 i
just don't believe the whole
no i don't think you [ __ ] 40 pounds
on it and i don't believe 200 yeah i
don't
we work with each other every day you
look exactly the same
okay and that's whatever yeah you'll
figure it out uh go see chappelle lacy
this friday and saturday austin texas
vulcan gas company show friday one show
saturday show friday one show saturday
so you signing off right now yeah what
do you got done just want to say one
thing i want to say thank you
obviously you weren't there so sorry
these two guys off camera are really
[ __ ] genuine and very very good
people you guys are real [ __ ] awesome
yeah straight up
like cameras and everything inside like
i just want you guys the fans to know
who are listening and you love these
guys yeah that
in person in real life like at the gym
no cameras you guys are [ __ ] dope
thanks brother
i appreciate you guys having me come on
and show them love yeah yeah yeah
this is great i want to add to that
these guys off camera man
these guys aren't here
this is real life right now the hell
with them
i can't say wolves or cats i can't
there's pressure on this podcast uh
next week i'm in cleveland ohio with
this crew man march 11th through the
13th
uh hilarity's cleveland ohio thursday
friday saturday
cleveland come get some spokane
washington uh all shows are sold out so
we added a show
on saturday one show so three shows on
saturday how many people go to these
uh just bends yeah you know
get them out i don't know how the
camera's rolling uh
yeah it's half capacity so like spokane
beach like 250 300 to show that's dope
but it's half capacity that sucks um
you've been a comedy show
uh i have a long time ago
like when i was i don't know 22. oh
you're in now
man oh you're in what is now yeah
uh miami florida march 25th to 27th
uh yeah man we're out there but
cleveland next week thursday friday
saturday hilarities
tickets at fatkz.com
and then merch uh the thick boy uh
nation jacket you see me rocking
and the hoodies all drop friday morning
at thickboy.com
where can i get that jacket though this
yeah this ain't for you
ah [ __ ] bradley we love you man hey hell
yeah yeah thanks for coming in brother
awesome